我記得喺八年之前，即係 2007 年
嗰年呢對我嚟講發生兩件好重要嘅事情
第一件事情呢就係我要做爸爸啦
咁我為咗要生小朋友
我就搬咗去一個好自然
有花園大樹嘅地方
一間小屋裏邊住
咁嗰度呢就做咗我
小朋友自然學習嘅地方啦
佢由出世到宜家
第二件事呢都好緊要對我嚟講
就我同一班好朋友開一間自然學校
間學校呢好重視人同自然嘅關係嘅
我哋覺得呢教育前面要加多兩個字
叫情意
而我哋講嘅係自然教育
所以就係情意之教
一般人都好忽視嘅
人嘅感情、人嘅情感
所以話我哋成日都會要
小朋友做好多功課
我哋其實愈富裕
無論家長、老師
都好關心小朋友嘅未來
之但係，佢哋關心嘅係咩呢？
就係佢有冇競爭力
早前有個朋友分享咗
一個咁樣嘅廣告俾我
你唔鍾意競爭咩？競爭會搵你嘅
面試班，幾多歲嘅面試班呀？
K1
哎呀原來我哋驚入唔到大學
驚入唔到好嘅中學
驚入唔到好嘅小學
驚到幼稚園都要驚
呢個其實係面試班
就專係對住嗰啲
好擔心嘅家長賣呢個廣告
我哋呢宜家嘅小朋友
朝早起身就返學校啦
返咗學校呢，放學
放學呢就去補習班
然後返屋企去做功課
其實冇咩機會接近自然嘅
宜家啲家長呢連暑假都唔放過嗰噃
家長都瘋狂哦
香港有間補習社通宵輪候排隊
幾多個家長去排隊呀
咁幾多號籌呀？
我聽講有人呢四點幾嚟排架
唔
我哋都唔係誇張架啦
今日六點三嚟到嘅
咁早都要嚟排隊？
其實唔早啦
我嚟到第 300 個人倒
你又排佢又排
講都冇人信
原來暑期報補習都要爭崩頭呀
沙田區一間補習社
星期日朝有成 700 人
唔去飲茶唔去街喺度排隊
有家長仲排通宵添
喺大陸呢都有一個咁樣嗰喎
呢個係早兩年前嘅分享
喺南京一個女仔寫咗首詩
跟著香港有兩個學生作咗首歌出嚟
南京早兩年前架啫
一個十二歲嘅女仔寫出嚟
佢覺得壓力好大呀
壓力大響咩地方度呀？
要計數
佢唔係玩遊戲
佢唔係玩公仔
佢唔係打遊戲機
只係喺度做數學題
好辛苦呀
可能成日都係咁樣樣
我曾經有一個學生
佢形容學校係乜嘢也？
係監獄呀
如果佢唔做功課嗰日就慘啦
小息都冇埋
放學就要補習
返屋企又要做功課
人同大自然呢完全係冇接觸架
你睇下呢個女仔
嗱。呢個完整嘅
佢想做啲咩嘢呀？
其實好想放個假，去探索下啲花花草草
係咁架咋喎
其實係好簡單咋喎細路仔
一啲都唔複雜
但係呢，但人嘅期望呢
就往往壓住啲細路仔
令到細路仔呢連一啲
好簡單嘅事情都做唔到
呢個呢係邊度架呢？
早幾排又有人分享喺荷蘭呀
有個報紙呢走去做調查呀
問下好多好好多嘅人，有大人，有細路
有五十件事你認為呢
要喺十二歲之前要做嘅
呢度舉咗其中幾件呀
有冇人做晒呢五件呀？舉手嚟睇下
五件都做過嘅
呢五件︰跳水溝
——原來跳個坑都咁好玩嘅
秘密基地、生火、爬樹、去露營
呢啲呀，原來呢
宜家嘅小朋友係冇乜機會做到呢啲嘢嘅
但係呢荷蘭人就覺得呢啲嘢好緊要架喎
十二歲之前要做架喎
咁中國係點呢？
我要做一個調查啦
於是乎我哋覺得自然學校就要做一件事
俾細路仔可以多啲接觸大自然
喺大自然裏邊玩遊戲、去愛上大自然
讓小朋友覺得大自然
係一個親切好玩嘅地方
呢啲呢就係我哋學校嘅學生啦
中間戴太陽眼鏡嗰個係邊個呢？
就係老師啦
一齊玩嘅
爬樹啦、搭閉所
隔籬你睇下嗰個好細個架咋
嗰個三歲嗰個女仔， 吓
隔籬嗰個係佢老師
跑步、奔跑、自由奔跑
香港呀我見過一個學校係咁樣樣呀
小息打鐘嘅時候你知唔知要做咩呀
鈴鈴…定形呀
好搞笑呀
其實啫係好得意呀我覺得呀
玩韆鞦、蕩韆鞦，呢個佢自己整嘅
老師即刻整嘅，喺棵樹下底吊出嚟
開懷大笑，係咪呀？
係咪好開心呀，好快樂呀？
開心個人就會咩呀？就會想學嘢啦
我哋自然學校辦學理念
其中一個最重要嘅
人就係大自然嘅一部分啦
所以自然教育就應該係好重要架嘛
係咪呀？
第二，我哋覺得每個人都想學嘢架喎
頭先有個教師都話細路仔好想學嘢嘅
不過唔想做功課咋嘛
其實細路仔好想學嘢嘅
我自己有兩個小朋友
我睇住佢大，都睇住佢可以好鐘意學嘢
我記得有一次
我個大女八個月，行路都未識行
屋企有兩個樓梯級
佢就喺度爬上去呀
第一次爬，爬咗幾耐呀？
六分鐘呀，我就睇住佢喺度爬
咁我覺得孩子係好需要大自然
好需要自己探索嘅時間
好需要冒險呀
所以呢，我就會帶細路仔做呢啲嘢啦
堅毅行麥理浩
東西橫走三十里
六位少年不畏苦
嘻嘻哈哈落山林
咁為咗我哋、慶祝我哋
可以呢喺香港依笪地方呢
我哋嘅另類教育可以搞到第五年呢
咁我哋今年呢有一個特別活動
咁除咗我哋四月一日嘅開放日之外呢
我哋呢有六位小朋友
就會決定呢就喺香港嘅郊野呢
由西貢行到返嚟
咁就用五日四夜嘅時間
除咗為咗我哋學校籌款呢
都希望向呢個大眾啦、或者香港政府呢
表達對於孩子需要大自然呢個要求呢
希望大家都會特別關注嘅
孩子需要大自然呀
我哋係真心咁覺得架
點解有咩咁好呀？
回歸自然就係人嘅天性啦
你會發覺人係鐘意望啲綠色嘅嘢架喎
小朋友見到啲小動物會好開心架喎
好想接觸佢架喎
身心靈健康
我聽講有一個講法就係話
當人去到大自然裏面行一個圈
個人都精神啲嘅、健康啲嘅
唔係剩係身體喎
連心靈都會健康啲嗰喎
如果可以經常都接觸大自然嘅就太好啦
用電腦呀，每隔一段時間
你就要望下一啲綠色嘅嘢
對眼睛好，係嗎？
親近大自然
因為喺大自然可以自由自在咁玩
個人個心呢就會變圓又軟
接納度高啲呀
所以我覺得好重要呀呢樣嘢
向大自然學習
我哋好多嘢可以喺大自然裏邊學嘢嘅
以自然為師嘅
我哋有個朋友擔天望地
有一日望個藍天就突然間
啟發自己做一件好重要嘅事情嗱
喺大自然裏面都培養到
小朋友嘅創造力嗰噃
咁我哋去露營
啲細路仔佢嘅經驗
然後有啲空閑嘅時間、無聊嘅時候
就係佢創造力嘅時候啦
咁係啲咩呢？佢就作咗首歌
嗰餐飯係啲小朋友煮俾我食架
用柴火煮
嗰餐嘅咖哩飯一陣間就食晒
不知幾好味
吓，平時有啲小朋友
我成日有時見到啲人係追住餵架嘛
係咪呀？
唔願食飯嘅，吓
因間就會再講一啲，吓
更重要嘅嚟講、對我嚟講就係話
要有一個讓我哋嘅教育下一代呀
可以有一個持續嘅發展嘅未來
唔係殺雞取卵呀，係嗎，吓
即咁樣樣，吓
所以呢，我哋覺得自然學校就要朝著
個細路仔多啲去大自然裏面接觸大自然
因間我哋會再講多啲
而我自然實際會點樣做呢？
嗱我簡單講下我哋自然學校
係一間好細嘅學校
私校嚟嘅
小班小校
小班嘅意思啫係十五個人一個班
小校就係全校宜家八十個學生
唔係好多架咋
由三到十二歲嘅學生都有
係七個班架啫全間學校
咁但係小就係希望微小
小啲官僚嘅嘢
小就係希望人同人之間
可以多啲親近同接觸
同事之間可以多啲有商有量
然後我就要營造一啲唔同嘅文化氣氛
亦都容易啲推行啦
自然學校就係為咗綠色嘅環境
我哋希望創造一個簡樸自然嘅學校生活
咁洗碗呢？
我哋都要要求學生洗碗小心啲洗喎
咁佢哋要諗呢啲方法啦
（諗咗一個咩係慳水嘅好貼士啦）
（好，咁大家記住囉喎，拜拜）
咁佢哋呢就搵嗰啲唔同嘅嘢
就做一樣嘢
其中呢，一個塑膠盤咁樣嘅嘢
就愛嚟洗碗嘅
吓，咁佢哋呢就係有
一盤番梘水、兩盤清水
咁佢哋自己就洗自己嘅碗，吓
佢哋洗之前呢就好似
以前啲阿嬸咁樣樣洗嘅
倒啲暖水落去
跟住呢就攪攪攪攪
將啲菜汁剩低嗰啲呢就攪勻佢、飲咗佢
吓，咁就乾淨咗好多
然後就先拎去洗
吓，番梘水洗一次
再用清水過兩次
自己抹返乾淨佢，放返原位就好乾淨啦
咁呢就好慳水架啦咁樣樣
學校呢，一般學校呢
香港學校呢就會有雞脾呀、熱狗食嘅
自然學校就冇呢啲嘢食嘅，吓
我哋食啲健康嘅嘢嘅
去露營啦，我哋去五日四夜嘅露營喎
自己起營、自己生火
吓，五日四夜
我記得嗰年帶三個架啫
三個第二屆嘅畢業生
佢哋呢五日四夜驚好耐呀
好似離開屋企未試過
但係呢到走嗰日
原來五日四夜真眨下眼就過
點架呀？開心、好玩、學到嘢
咁我哋都好重視生活教育
有生活會議呀、生活法庭啦
勞動學習等等
生活法庭我特別講下生活法庭啦
好得意嘅
同學之間會有好多拗撬架
咁如果有同學，我同你之間覺得你搞我
我唔鐘意你
一般就教告俾老師聽啦
告俾爸爸媽媽聽啦
佢唔係，告上生活法庭
寫低自己個名，寫低個
時間、地點、日期、事件經過
自己嘅感受好緊要喎
我哋講情感嘛，感受好緊要呀
然後簽名，攞去校務處
「唔該，我告呢個人。」
咁呢就會開庭，有法官嘅
法官係一個老師加兩個學生
全部都係全校選出嚟嘅
係公信力夠嘅人先做到法官
咁就審案啦咁樣樣
我哋好重視輔導啦
我哋冇社工架
邊啲人做呀？
老師自己，老師自己做呢樣嘢
老師係最清楚自己嘅學生架啦
我哋每個學生呢都有自己嘅評估嘅
唔單止老師寫俾佢
佢自己都寫俾自己嘅
佢都要評估下自己
自己呢年個情況係點樣樣
我記得呢有幾個問題問啲低年班嘅
「你最鍾意咩嘢呀？
你最唔鐘意咩嘢呀？
你覺得最擅長係啲咩呀？
你最想學嘅係咩呀？」
咁我個女呢啱啱今年讀一年班嘞
佢又畫咗啦
我就問佢你最擅長係咩嘢呀？
估你都估唔到
佢話佢最擅長
因為佢畫嘅我唔知講乜呀
我話最擅長嘅做功課哇
最想學嘅係咩嘢呀？英文呀
嘩！真係想像唔到
一般學校最唔鍾意做嘅功課啦
最唔想學嘅英文啦，係咪先？
頭先有講啦，自主學習
一般嘅課堂中英數之外
亦都有啲興趣小組
我哋學法官係民選出嚟嘅
自己編嘅教材
自己按學生嘅程度、進度嚟教學
唔需要去同人哋比較
評估唔係剩係只得評估嘅
唔係剩係考試嘅
有口頭評估，有導師嘅觀察
個人畢業專題
每個學生畢業嘅時候
要做一個自己嘅研習
後邊呢我會講一個
我好難忘嘅畢業專題
另外要做畢業露營會呀
一共去五日四夜嘅吓
咁呢啲呢就係我哋學生嘅功課嘅作品嘞
吓，咁佢哋平時畫嘅圖啦
觀察嘅、有畫嘅自然筆記啦
呢個係佢哋嘅視藝作品啦
用啲廢料去做嘅
搵自然物件去做嘅
呢個呢，數學功課嚟架
數學功課嚟架
吓，叫佢畫，我要佢出一個題目
用四則運算嚟作一個故仔出嚟
吓，作咗個笑話出嚟
呢個，吓，幾過癮
數學功課做完之後呢
可以畫下自己嘅感受嘅
係咪呀，喺下底
呢個呀，太容易啦
吓，我記得呢有個畫，真係幾難嘅
佢話難到生鬚呀噉樣樣
呢個我哋中文科嘅功課啦，寫詩啦
跟住呢個呢就係英文啦
英文做一個 second hand 嘅
free market
跟住就做一個 poster 咁樣樣
呢個呢就係畢業專題嘅功課嘞
一個學生用半年時間學畫畫
佢唔識嘅，跟著就學畫咗呢個出嚟
然後就喺，好似我宜家咁樣樣
喺全校嘅學生面前做
報告佢自己學習成果
跟著呢個呢，呀，佢就有咁嘅題目啦
佢走去問啲學生、問啲老師
你知唔知牛奶係點樣嚟架？
原來啲學生老師都唔係好知架
你有冇諗過？
點解啲牛可以源源不絕都有牛奶出架？
乜唔係剩係生完 BB 先有架咩？
佢成年都有奶出嗰噃
咁佢喺度調查呢樣嘢啦
人點樣對待佢呢？
佢就去做個實驗喎
點做個實驗呀？
嗰啲呢，嗰啲衫呀
啫晾完衫跟著咪收落一個籃裏邊咁嘅
佢攤喺學校裏面，叫啲同學捐入去
「你覺得點呀而家咁樣樣？」
然後就模擬啲牛係咁樣俾人養
咁佢就要做個報告啦
好精細做完個 powerpoint
然後佢就做咗個結論啦
我覺得好深刻
當最後嘅物種，動物絕種啦
樹都俾人斬晒啦
水源都俾人污染啦
人就會發現一件事啦
錢唔食得飽嘅
如果你剩係得錢嘅話，係咪呀？
你錢愛嚟買嘢食架嘛
但係呢啲都冇晒嘅時候，你食乜嘢呀？
唔好食，好真實架喎
我最近睇關於大陸嗰個污染問題
嗰霧霾嘅問題
原來真係好大件事架
係會死人架
每年有五十萬
因為空氣污染而死咗嘅人呀
唔少架
咁我自己覺得係好多好多嘢
細路仔好需要玩，需要遊戲嘅時間
需要愛，需要大自然
呢個我個大女，零七年出世嗰個
呢個係我細女，零九年出世
咁我就成日帶佢去大自然嗰度玩啦
我希望帶佢哋去大自然感受自然嘅美
（哦係呀，你睇緊太陽伯伯出嚟呀？）
我就係想細路仔識呢樣嘢咋
曉欣賞，懂珍惜
原來都唔容易嘅其實，吓
不過希望我哋下一代可以做到呢樣嘢
好，多謝各位
（掌聲）